good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us us on this wonderful
beautiful fall afternoon we could not
have asked for more gorgeous weather so
it's very kind of you to give up this
lovely autumn day to be here with us and
I will tell you it is absolutely worth
it because it is really a true delight
to be able to honor our wonderful rosa
DeLauro so welcome you here to the Yale
Law School Auditorium and our fall chub
fellowship lecture with our
distinguished guests the Honorable rosa
DeLauro our representative in Congress
for Connecticut's 3rd congressional
district but before we begin today's
program I ask that you all turn off your
cell phones and refrain from taking any
photographs while congresswoman DeLauro
is speaking today my name is Mary Lou
I'm a professor in the Department of
History and the programs of American
Studies and ethnicity race and migration
I'm also the head of college for Timothy
Dwight College and as the head of
Timothy Dwight College I have the honor
of serving as the custodian of the
illustrious chub Fellowship established
in 1941 out of a prior large donation
for education purposes made in 1936 by
hendon chub a graduate of the Yale class
of 1895 since establishment the chub
fund has a hereto the goals of providing
encouragement and aid to students
interested in government and American
public affairs the fellowship initially
aimed to foster among Yale
undergraduates an interest in public
service in local and state affairs and
this fellowship has grown over the years
to include numerous distinguished
visitors in national and international
affairs as well as leaders in the world
of the Arts and the humanities since the
1940s the chub Fellowship lecture series
has inspired generations of Yale
students to undertake public service and
pursue Liddy's ship roles in the hopes
of creating a
better world today and for posterity the
fellowship has hosted four US presidents
George HW Bush Gerald Ford Jimmy Carter
and Harry Truman in recent years we've
welcomed a wide range of national and
international leaders including highly
decorated Olympic skater Michelle Kwan
visual artist faith Ringgold
environmental activist Bill McKibben
physician in humanitarian dr. hawa Abdi
former Secretary of Transportation and
commerce as well as congressman Norman
Mineta songwriter and musician Paul
Simon and many others so with this very
quick description of the history and
aims of the Chubb fellowship I am
delighted that we are honoring today
representative rosa DeLauro with her 28
years of distinguished service she's
currently the fourth longest-serving
congresswoman in the House of
Representatives Rosa de Lara was born in
New Haven Connecticut and began her
illustrious career in public office soon
after completing her degrees from
Marymount College and Columbia
University she followed her parents
Theodore and Louisa DeLauro into public
service both of her parents were beloved
leaders in Worcester Square and served
on the Board of Aldermen for the city of
New Haven her mother louisa de lara was
the longest-serving Alder in the history
of New Haven representative DeLauro has
served as the first executive director
of Emily's list a national organization
dedicated to increasing the number of
women in elected office and I think
we've seen some of the most wonderful
gains in recent years of women in office
and I think it's really to her credit
that that has happened in 1990
representative de Laura was elected to
the House of Representatives from
Connecticut's 3rd congressional district
and has served as the congresswoman for
our district ever since in her 28 years
in office she has fought for the
nation's working families by supporting
raising the minimum wage giving
employees access to paid sick days and
taking family and medical leave and
helping women to achieve equal pay for
equal work
representative DeLauro serves as a
Democrat
leadership as co-chair of the Democratic
steering and Policy Committee as the
chair of the labor health Human Services
and education Appropriations
Subcommittee she's working to increase
support for education and resources to
make college affordable for all she has
fought to protect the Affordable Care
Act to keep health care accessible and
work to increase funding for biomedical
research in 2017 she published the least
among us waging the battle for the
vulnerable with the new press that
eloquently defends the importance of
maintaining and improving the social
safety net for all
so we're deeply honored to have such a
distinguished guest join the ranks of
the Chubb fellowship this year as Yale
celebrates the 50th anniversary of
co-education in Yale College in the
150th anniversary of women's students at
the University I'm especially delighted
that we're honoring representative
DeLauro as our fall chub fellow please
join me in welcoming representative
DeLauro to the stage
[Applause]
my word thank you very very much thank
you Mary for such a very warm
introduction and you mentioned my
parents I will mention them as well I
think they're looking down and saying my
god she is speaking at the Yale Law
School and isn't that quite
extraordinary
but I want to just first say to you Mary
that how honored I am to have been
selected to be the fall of 2019 sub
fellow I take the honor I want you to
know this I take this honor not as a
recognition of past deeds but as a call
if you will to push harder to help to
make a difference in people's lives let
me recognize a few people if I can and
to you Mary starting a fifth year I
guess you know in heading up Timothy
Dwight I said to Mary and walking in
many years ago was asked to be an
Associate Fellow at Timothy Dwight but
the meetings were always like on a
Tuesday night and I could never get
there and I just assumed they would turn
me out you know and say you don't show
up for the meeting so you know you're no
longer but they've they've hung in with
me over the years so but you have
brought to bear your experience as a
historian and you are helping to promote
an atmosphere that fosters conversation
sparks awareness in our students today
you help them to see how their world is
shaped how it shapes them and how they
can shape it PD is a residential college
steeped in history named for two former
Yale presidents and a father and son
Timothy Dwight the fourth and the fifth
were among yells most influential
presidents the son oversaw the
transition of Yale from a regional
clergy college to a university that
would become a leader in global
education
let me also say a thank you where's Mary
Kay Kaminski thank you for helping to
organize this effort and for working so
close with our office I would also like
to recognize your president a dear
friend Peter salivate
he has been integral my view and turning
this University's attention to elevating
justice and opportunity two weeks ago he
and Yale helped to host a conference
which was honoring the 100th anniversary
of the founding of the UN's
International Labour Organization the
ILO it was called an entitled valuing
woman's work and building women's
economic empowerment it was rich in
content and in participation and the
quality was outstanding so we say thank
you to you president salivate for all
that you do to keep Yale and New Haven
at the intersection of international
history and global change and finally to
the students the faculty the community
members thank you for being here and
welcoming me so warmly to be selected as
a chubb fellow is a great honor created
as Mary pointed out in 1949 the Jub
fellowship is to foster an interest in
public service among Yale undergraduates
it was started with support from Hendon
Chubb an 1895 graduate of Yale's
Sheffield scientific school he was a
leader in the insurance industry for
half-century called buy insurance
network in 1945 as an I quote the
leading authority on marine underwriting
in America he helped grow the insurance
company that his father and his held a
brother Percy founded in 1882 to become
one of the largest of its kind in the
world he used that success to support
philanthropy including my hobby
create the Victoria Foundation one of
the oldest private foundations in the
United States he was not far from
government service he served as director
of war insurance of the war risk
insurance and as insurance advisor to
the United States shipping board there
he helped her financially protect the
men the ships and the cargo that was
crucial to the USS victory in World War
one and during the war he served as an
insurance advisor to the American Red
Cross he then helped bring that
commitment to leadership and government
to Yale with the Chubb fellowship and
over the years his fellowship at Yale
has grown to include numerous
distinguished visitors in national and
international affairs past recipients
include US presidents on both sides of
the aisle as you heard newscasters like
Walter Cronkite artists like Maya
Angelou foreign dignitaries US Supreme
Court justices US cabinet secretaries
ambassadors senators members of Congress
and mayors so for me to be recognized
with individuals of such status and
import please be truly humbled I am the
daughter of a hard-working Italian
immigrant family who could only dare to
dream that their daughter one day would
serve in the United States House of
Representatives my father who came in
1913 actually 1913 when he came he had
been in high school
and growing up in Italy but they put him
in the seventh grade when he came here
and he left in the seventh grade because
his teachers and classmates laughed at
him because he could not speak
the English language or write the
English language they asked him to
define the word janitor and he didn't
know what it meant but he drew on his
Italian language and he looked thought
about the term Jenni toady and that
means parents and family and that's the
way he described the word janitor well
they laughed at him he walked away from
school but went on to serve his
community and to serve his country with
distinction he fought for immigrants
came to New Haven he fought for their
rights he fought for getting the Italian
language taught in the New Haven Public
Schools my mother worked in the old
sweatshops on State Street here in New
Haven which is not very far from here
they were both elected officials in city
government my mom Louisa went on to
become the New Haven's longest-serving
alder which is our City Council and not
just the longest-serving woman their
brand of politics was about using
government to help people and to be able
to create opportunity for people they
didn't develop policy they didn't write
Omnibus legislation but what they did
was they made government work for people
who were struggling they worked
tirelessly to help people in need our
kitchen table was their office they
would do everything humanly possible to
help someone's kid get his or her first
job and to defend the neighborhood they
fought with their parish priest to care
more about the poor than about the
church's collection basket they taught
me that government can expand
opportunity move us to greater equality
that can help ensure the life health and
the dignity of families that we can
build social insurance against
misfortune and they taught me that we
have entered
generational responsibilities through
each other we have a moral obligation to
help the most vulnerable and that we are
not every man or woman for himself or
herself that has been my mission
throughout my career and in particular
throughout my tenure in the Congress to
serve in government as they did I
understand the power that government has
to impact people's lives now Francis
Perkins
once described her mission serving under
President Franklin Delano Roosevelt she
was the secretary of the Department of
Labor and a primary author of the New
Deal programs including Social Security
she said and I quote I came to
Washington to work for God FDR and the
millions of Forgotten plain common
working men I would add women today but
I too went to Washington to work on
behalf of the working people of this
country late in 2008 I flew to Chicago
to meet the then president-elect Barack
Obama to interview for the cabinet
position of Secretary of Labor I told
the president-elect that my role model
was Frances Perkins as I said the first
female Secretary of Labor and when she
was interviewed by FDR she presented to
him what she wanted to accomplish
minimum wage protection work hours
legislation workmen's compensation
workplace safety regulations federal aid
for unemployment a national pension
system as well as a system for health
insurance
I told president-elect Obama I wanted to
be a labor secretary
like Francis Perkins I also told him
that whether or not I got the job I
would continue to advocate for what I
believed in from wherever forum that I
found myself and now I serve as the
chair of the Appropriations Subcommittee
which funds the Department of Labor as
well as the department's of Health and
Human Services and education it is one
third of this country's non-defense
discretionary spending after the
Department of Defense labor HHS has the
largest command and portfolio of
programs that affect people's daily
lives and resources it's approximately
200 billion dollars a year from that
vantage point I have the opportunity to
put into action the values on which I
have centered my career government has
the capacity to help people to advance
the common good and even more as I said
a moment ago I believe government has a
moral obligation to do so for the sake
of working people and for the vulnerable
growing up in New Haven
I saw ample evidence all around me of
just how vulnerable hard-working people
are in the face of corporate
indifference in 1957 when I was barely a
teenager the Franklin Street fire
claimed the life of my friend's mother
15 people died in that disastrous fire
because they could not escape the smoke
and the flames a fire escape was locked
the latter would not extend to the
ground
there hadn't had not been any fire
drills the doors opened the wrong way
blocking exits
it wasn't disaster and it happened down
the street from my house it was
impossible to be an eyewitness to an
event like that and not be touched by
the gravity of our responsibility to one
another it bears repeating and I wrote a
book and Mary mentioned that I wrote a
book about my legislative fights in the
Congress to empower the vulnerable and I
opened with this it bears repeating that
corporations do not feel free to poison
us sela spoiled me lock our daughters up
in ninth floor sweatshops with no fire
escapes employ our underage sons in coal
mines forces to work thirteen hour
shifts without overtime or a break or
call in private armies to fire rifles at
those of us who dare strike for higher
wages it's not because corporation
experienced a moment of Zen and decided
to evolve no they were forced into
greater accountability and social
concern by the legitimate actions of a
democratic small d-- government in other
words if we depend on goodwill we are
all screwed that is my inspiration that
is what motivates me and it is a value
reflected in this nation social safety
net what is the social safety net it is
making sure that people get a break
particularly in difficult times
technically the social safety net is an
array of government programs that ensure
that no American will fall so far down
the socio-economic ladder that getting
back up on their feet becomes impossible
it is making sure that kids do not get
punished for their parents poverty the
programs include Medicare Medicaid
Affordable Care Act to help the sick
Social Security to help our seniors food
stamps to help the hungry minimum wage
and broad-based income supports like
unemployment insurance and a child tax
credits they are more than just programs
it is about being accountable to one
another our safety net is one of the
country's greatest legacies and it set
the stage for a century of unparalleled
prosperity that made the United States a
beacon for the world
it was not something dreamed up by
idioms with an agenda to weaken the
average Americans moral fiber the safety
nets growth was incremental it was in a
genuine response to systemic crises for
40 years these efforts were supported by
Republicans and Democrats alike I did
the research it's all there that when we
faced challenges in this nation despite
our differences our philosophies we said
we must act and we did these laws were
not written by naive people these
Democrats and Republicans understood why
they came to the Congress and the social
safety net acknowledges that progress on
the whole makes us richer more powerful
but that is also leads through
incredible uncertainty and volatility
they realized
that safeguards against familial
financial calamity benefited both the
unfortunate and those in better
circumstances
by preserving broad-based stability and
confidence in the future Columbia
University School of Social Work their
Center on poverty and social policy
recently estimated the report that
poverty has fallen nearly 40 percent
since the 1960s and much of that
reduction is due to our social safety
net programs each year each year Social
Security lifts twenty six point five
million people out of poverty the Earned
Income Tax Credit the child tax credit
lifts nine point one people out of
poverty the food stamp program four and
a half million people SSI three point
three million housing assistance two and
a half million and yet some have become
so determined to destroy the safety that
safety net and make government
illegitimate we have seen it over and
over again with Newt Gingrich with Paul
Ryan and now with President Trump I was
elected to the Congress in 1990 and
served two terms in the majority it's
good to be in the majority I might add I
was determined to be a legislator but
the Gingrich revolution changed that
trajectory my book shows that I had to
combine my political and organizing
skills with a determination to legislate
change Newt Gingrich's Contract with
America include many elements intended
to curtail the role of government that
includes closing the Department of
Education eliminating the National
Endowment for the Arts
and ending the school lunch program it
was the kind of madness that enabled us
to mobilize around the country and
circle the US Capitol with protesting
kids induced with ice cream I might add
contributed by Ben and Jerry's but they
sent 20,000 paper plates to members of
Congress saying don't egg my school
lunch that time Republicans were
determined to cut 270 billion dollars
from Medicare turn it into a system of
underfunded health clinics that would
quote wither on the vine to achieve that
they led the first-ever shutdown of the
federal government and lost but they
have not failed entirely for the last
two or three decades these efforts have
been successful in undermining the
collective strength of working people by
starving funding at the federal level
and by anti-union laws in the states now
union membership is half what it was in
the 1980s and the erosion of units of
worker protections of stagnant wages has
coincided with a dramatic rise in
inequality we saw tax giveaways for the
richest Americans in 2001 2003 2017 the
consequences spiked inequality reduces
our capacity to invest in infrastructure
and in education just to name a few the
attacks did not end there Paul Ryan was
empowered with the Tea Party's rise in
2010 and he used the moment to try to
end Medicare and Medicaid as we know
them again to leave Social Security to
privatize it
to let it wither on the vine in fact and
his first major policy speech a Speaker
of the House Paul Ryan said that 45
million Americans living in poverty were
a quote stuck in neutral he said that we
needed to get them quote off the
sidelines and he famously called the
social safety net and I quote a hammock
that lulls able-bodied people to lives
of dependency and complacency he lived
up to his words when he's chairman of
the House Budget Committee he achieved
two-thirds of his budget savings by
cutting from programs designed to help
working families and the poor Paul
Ryan's ideas exposed the reason behind
his thinking on poverty if you can only
make receiving government aid onerous
enough and humiliating enough then
people will opt out voluntarily redouble
their efforts to avoid hunger illness or
being laid off that idea is a slap in
the face to the millions who do
everything right and still cannot get by
it is a betrayal of a legacy of good
government in the United States and now
the current administration has
nationalized the battle against
government we are witnessing the most
massive assault on the social safety net
in recent history everything is at risk
and we are watching an historic push
back by the American people and I might
add starting with the women's March and
ending with last year's Blue Wave women
voters in particular have led the push
back unmarried women as women who are
widowed single divorced or separated
white working-class women
college-educated and some
Bourbon women have led the way and are
leading the way women candidates were
victorious in the Democratic primaries
and the election and in 2018 we produced
the most diverse US House of
Representatives in our nation's history
100 women the most women ever and now
women cheers six full committees and 39
subcommittees in the house when more
women are at the table it's not a
question of numbers it's about the
agenda changing and what are the issues
that we take up the agenda is
transformed and the agenda has been
transformed for the people they were
reacting to a government that was
disproportionately hurting women let me
just give you some examples in the
departments that I oversee the
Department of Health and Human Services
decreased nursing home protections for
seniors 70% of whom are women it
attacked contraceptive care costing
women 1.4 billion dollars more per year
in co-payments it went after Planned
Parenthood title 10 and comprehensive
sex education Department of Education
rolled back protections for sexual
assault survivors allowed predatory
for-profit colleges to get away with
financially exploiting women seeking a
college education women comprise 65
percent of all students at for-profit
colleges and they hold two-thirds of
outstanding student debt roughly about
eight hundred billion dollars the
Department of Agriculture limited
millions of women's access to
anti-hunger programs including food
stamps women are twice as likely as men
to have received fruit stands which has
kept approximately forty 2.2 million
people all over the country from growing
from going hungry
just a moment on hunger people presume
that that's somewhere else I will just
tell you that in the third congressional
district that I represent 25 towns one
out of seven people every night goes to
bed not knowing where their next meal is
coming from
we have a hunger issue not only in this
state but all over the country we
mentioned the Department of Labor it
unraveled the overtime rule which would
have provided overtime pay protections
to 3.2 million women the Office of
Management and Budget also effectively
received reversed steps by the Obama
administration to fix the gender pay gap
made it more difficult Department of
Labor has made it more difficult to
organize and to engage in collective
bargaining these actions were a
systematic attack on women rightly
called
out as a war on women and now the US
House of Representatives is moving the
country in a different direction who is
at the table matters we are using our
platform as the majority in the House to
rewrite the rules to restore the balance
between corporations and labor and to
restore America's promise to help
working people the US House passed I'll
say my I don't mean to be self-serving
but it is my equal pay bill which I
introduced in 1997 the Paycheck Fairness
Act passed with the large bipartisan
majority 242 to 187 with seven
Republicans in favor it's a very simple
premise men and women in the same job
deserve the same pay no more than that
it's true in the United States Congress
we come from all over the country
different skill sets different
educational backgrounds we all get paid
the same it's not true the rest of the
country for others there are more women
than ever are working in the American
economy however women still make just 82
cents on average of the man's dollar
across every profession a gap that
increases even more when you look at the
wages of latina and black women but the
Paycheck Fairness Act will mean is
essential progress in the fight to
eliminate the gender wage gap and to
help families and it's my fervent hope
that it will be the first bill signed by
a new Democratic president
[Applause]
the US House of Representatives has also
passed raise the wage act to raise the
federal minimum wage to $15 an hour by
2025 it's been ten years since the last
increase the longest period was between
increases in the history of the federal
minimum wage it is clearly time and it
will raise wages for 34 million
Americans you know the thing is biggest
economic challenge we have today is that
people are in jobs that don't pay them
enough to deal with the rising costs of
health care child care education just
they live from paycheck to paycheck
I work with many of my allies in moving
what I have called and coined to working
families agenda the Healthy Families Act
for paid sick days in the Senate
Washington State Senator patty Murray is
the sponsor the United States is the
only developed country that does not
guarantee paid sick days we don't care
and there's no maternity care the United
States you can hardly believe that the
family act for paid leave I first
introduced it with Senator Ted Kennedy
in 2004 and now with senator Kirsten
Gillibrand losing weeks worth of wages
in order to care for an ill loved one
would push many families over the
financial edge but only 14% of private
sector workers earned paid family leave
through their employers and fewer than
40% have access it's a personal medical
leave my mom passed away two years ago
the last six weeks of her life she spent
between Yale New Haven Hospital and
hospice my husband and I were there
every single day
no one told me your job isn't there no
one said you can't get paid it should
not be only for members of Congress the
country needs to have paid sick days so
they can take care of themselves or
their families in a time of crisis the
schedules at Work Act with senator
Elizabeth Warren too few workplaces
provide the 21 point six million workers
in low-wage service sector jobs with
schedules that allow them to succeed in
fact a survey of the early career
employees found that 41% of hourly
workers get their schedules only a week
or less in advance and nearly half of
these workers have no input into their
schedules the American family act to
strengthen and expand the child tax
credit introduced in the Senate by
Senator sherrod Brown and Senators
Michael Bennett it would cut poverty in
half in a decade an anomaly in the
current law blocks one-third of needy
children from the full benefits of the
child tax credit a recent study found
that the American Family Act would help
over 700,000 children in Connecticut by
D linking the child tax credit from
income so that families will no longer
be ineligible for the full benefit
because they earn too little many are
excluded today because they earned too
little the very people who need to have
that kind of financial help and I am
proudly using the gavel of the labor HHS
as the labor health and education
Appropriations Subcommittee we've been
holding hearings to put a spotlight on
the alarming and awful and often illegal
conduct of the administration
we have hosted 16 oversight and budget
hearings on e cigarettes and vaping on
the crisis of unaccompanied minors being
separated and detained at the southern
border on predatory for-profit colleges
federal student loan servicing the
unaccompanied children program waged the
theft and the administration's cost
increasing changes to the Affordable
Care Act and Gun Violence Prevention
Research as part of that work we have
hosted hearings on and if I take a
minute really to talk about the
treatment of unaccompanied children at
the border and the intentional policy
choices by the administration which have
resulted in what I term
government-sponsored child abuse and
trauma the reason why I engaged in this
effort is because in the subcommittee
that I chair is something called the
office of refugee resettlement Orr we
are responsible for the unaccompanied
children who come across the border the
Department of Homeland Security is an
immigration enforcement agency in
essence what Health and Human Services n
o RR is it if you will is a child
welfare agency department of homeland
security security takes them holds them
for what they're supposed to be for not
more than 72 hours and then shifts them
over to the jurisdiction of Health and
Human Services I provided a bipartisan
briefing by the office of the Inspector
General of Health and Human Services to
let our colleagues know what was going
on no press no fanfare just to get a
sense of what was happening
last year I toured facilities I was in
the Kalin Texas and in Brownsville to
see what was there it was worse than I
had ever imagined children were in cages
very high they're not covered with the
top and so forth with his but these high
page linked fences it was staggering
what was more staggering was and my
colleague jim Himes congressman Himes
from connecticut we went to visit one of
those detention centers where they hold
the children for 72 hours we peered into
a room and it was like mylar you know
this is very thin mylar silver it was
like covering the floor and we were
talking all of a sudden the mylar
started to move and out from under the
mylar for all of these children under
that blanket to keep warm because I
don't make this up short sleeves it's a
hot climate but they're taken into very
cold rooms rubbing their arms
I was spoke to mothers I spoke to
daughters people who were held in
separate cells
I spoke to more than a dozen mothers who
had not seen their children in over a
month
they were sobbing they had no idea were
there children were
the administration initiated a zero
tolerance policy of separating children
at the border and at the time the chief
of staff general Kelly was asked if this
was a way to deter immigration he said
yes so it was a conscious policy to
deter immigration and what's the
harshest thing that you might be able to
do to a family ask yourselves they took
your child you were one place your child
another and you don't know where they
are they don't know where you work you
can't think about this you go to a
restaurant to eat you put your coat in
the cloakroom they give you a claim
check you go to the cleaners you drop
your clothes off they give you a claim
check you put your luggage in storage
they give you a claim check I will tell
you there was no claim check for your
child it was only because of the ACLU
that we've been able in many instances
to reunite children with their families
over 4,000 children separated from their
families you can imagine the terror not
just for the parents but haven't child
who doesn't know for his or her mother
or father yes or feeling abandoned and
what damage that is doing and has done
to these children
earlier this year I visited what they
call is an influx facility in Homestead
Florida I'm frankly I'm hoping to get
word within the next little while that
we're gonna shut down the homestead
facility on our visit we confirmed that
the federal government is using federal
property to skirt federal standards of
care failing to have fully adequate
mental health providers education
facilities I wasn't there I visited I
saw it they were failing to get children
out quickly as is their responsibility
the mission of of Health and Human
Services with these children is to put
them in a safe i highlight the word safe
environment as quickly and as
expeditiously as possible so we were
told by some of the children that they
had been there for 44 days 56 days 60
days when in fact they do have family
members in the United States so what has
been the holdup I just give you this
last two facts last December there were
15,000 children in detention in the u.s.
kids who kind of cross the border either
they were separated from their family
and then they became unaccompanied or
came unaccompanied the reason why we're
not they were not moving them out
quickly was because of policies and an
agreement between Health and Human
Services and homeland security what is
it what was the agreement you come
forward as a sponsor for one of these
children we find out that you are
undocumented you then are deported so
the whole network of sponsors dried up
no one coming forward the other piece
was again I come forward I would like to
take one of these children and in fact
and I believe in this you've met the
person fingerprint and make sure that
this is a safe safe environment for this
child
they decided them to sing fingerprint
ever
person in the household it ground the
process to a halt they subsequently
changed those under a lot of pressure
and I would they told me that shortly
after they did this that they were moved
8,000 children out of the process in
record time so they could have been
doing this all along and not putting
these kids through all this difficulty
our worst fears were confirmed by the
office of the inspector general their
latest report confirmed that intentional
policy choices by the administration
created a mental health crisis with
children which the Office of Inspector
General said that Health and Human
Services and the Office of refugee
resettlement failed to address it is a
crisis of deliberate as I said in my
view government sanctioned child abuse
but we have worked to put a spotlight on
this you've also brought up members of
the president's cabinet to ensure
they're holding up their mission and
advancing policies that benefit working
families we held a hearing in March with
Education Secretary Betsy two votes in
those remarks he emphasized the need for
greater oversight around charter schools
I reminded secretary Davos that the
teachers striking to get fair wages are
not hurting our schools and students as
she tried to claim it is her attempt to
gut public education that is hurting our
schools and students the three education
budgets from the administration have
proposed the largest cuts to education
funding since the department was created
in 1979 but I will just tell you and
again it probably sounds self-serving to
you as long as I am chair of this
subcommittee those cuts will not happen
we are committed to defending public
schools students and staff and this year
we held the first appropriations hearing
on gun violence prevention research in
20 years we have been
precluded from even holding a hearing on
research and finding out how we can
prevent gun violence the experts told us
that the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention and the National Institutes
of Health can do and must do this
research so we provided in the
appropriations bill 50 million dollars
the Department of Labor its mission is
to quote to foster promote and develop
the welfare of wage earners job seekers
and retirees of the United States
improve working conditions advance
opportunities for profitable employment
and assure work-related benefits and
rights yet the administration has
hollowed out the Department of Labor to
take the agency from enforcement to
compliance from weeding out bad actors
through offering bad actors technical
assistance from being a tough cop on the
beat to being a friend of Industry we
pressed and their that the then head of
the Department of Labor
Alex Acosta on why only 43% of the
department's senior roles were filled
compared to 80% under previous
administration's the Department of Labor
was tied for the worst in the entire
federal government it was not just the
staff but the protections for working
people
they allowed franchises contractors and
subcontractors staffing agencies to
commit wage theft they allowed child
labor in health professions putting teen
air teenagers at risk of injury they
blocked electronic reporting preventing
the public from knowing detailed
workplace injury information they
shortchanged three million American
workers from getting their overtime they
weakened protections for construction
and shipyard workers from beryllium
exposure they allowed contractors who
cheat their workers to continue with
quote business as usual their roll backs
to coal dust rules and the like have
coincided with a 25 year high
a black lung cases in Appalachian coal
mining States under this administration
the Department of Labor has become a
shell of an agency it is not just the
fight over policy that we are facing
look you are seeing every day a
constitutional crisis democracy is at
stake
we take democracy for granted in this
country we do democracy is fragile but
we have a president who was indifferent
to the law and different to right and
wrong and indifferent to the limits
imposed by the Constitution I was very
reluctant to call for an impeachment
inquiry
why because I feared it would continue
to divide the country I was concerned
that we would relitigate the 2016
election and ultimately if it went to
the United States Senate I thought that
regardless of the evidence that there
would not be any conviction but given
the turn of events in the last month I
concur with the chairman of the
Intelligence Committee at Adam Schiff
that we have crossed the Rubicon using
the power of office to invite a foreign
power to interfere in our elections is
illegal recent revelations unveil a
pattern of confirmed abuse of power by
the president was holding foreign aid in
exchange for an investigation of a
political opponent
but as I am watching this as the chair
of labor HHS of that subcommittee and as
someone who could share the full
Appropriations Committee in 2021 I'm
aware that it is a different kind of
constitutional crisis they are
successfully hollowing out government
eradicating protections for workers and
women taking us back to a time when
corporations were unchecked stopping
President Trump is not enough we need to
mobilize we need to build up to getting
back to a time when both parties worked
together where they understood that the
social safety net is our shared legacy
and how to make it stronger and not how
to destroy it that is why I think of the
words of a hero of mine shirley Chisholm
shirley Chisholm was the first African
American woman to be elected to the
Congress she once said and I quote they
should they asked her how do you make
progress and she said you don't make
progress by standing on the sidelines by
whimpering and complaining you make
progress by implementing ideas that is
what we must be doing we should not rely
on the goodwill of corporations we
should not abandon government for the
common good we should not believe we can
simply stand on the sidelines whimpering
or complaining and see change we must
return to a time when both parties
agreed to build the social safety net to
make opportunity real for people we must
be mobilizing all of civil society to
reclaim our country and our history we
need to demand progress and we need to
demand our country back thank you for
honoring me as a folde 2019 shot fellow
I take it as a responsibility
[Applause]
two of our aides
are going to come around with the
microphone we have time for probably two
questions thank you all very very much
thank you questions question not a shy
audience yeah go ahead
no the Merit Systems Protection Board is
designed to protect four million federal
employees and there are no judges on the
appeals panel it's been that way for
almost three years no case has been
heard is there anything that can be done
to protect my rights I mean I am polite
so I am it's what I strive for it's what
I'm looking for is legislation that
protects people's rights unless we have
a change in this Department of Labor and
people understand the need for
protection it will not change it will
not what the most unbelievable thing for
me these days is there's so much that is
on TV all important stuff please don't
misunderstand me but foundationally of
what is being eroded is not coming
across to the American people it just
isn't quite frankly it doesn't sell TV
ratings or newspapers it is and that is
what honestly and it's not hyperbole it
really is what it keeps me up because
you cannot
there's so many holes you can't your
have enough fingers to keeping the Dyke
here so that you can prevent some of
these things from happening we're trying
doing our best and look if people say we
are not passing legislation I just tell
you there are 375 bills some are more or
less important that are at the doorstep
of the United States Senate and Mitch
McConnell will not move he self
describes as the grim reaper I would
never describe myself in those terms I
mean my gosh you know but that's where
it's going but you're right your rights
are being eroded and we are trying
we need just we need people who
understand you know the Department of
Labor the NLRB what is all at stake here
how do we take back those rights that we
fought so hard for over the years and it
frightens me
I would I would lie to you but you know
of you know it's like saying you know
through your fingers and you can't you
can't get hold of it so please stand up
we continue to fight you know my mom
also tell me two things never take no
for an answer and never give up
so you're just damn the torpedoes full
steam ahead which is what we need to do
over the next was it 13 months okay
[Applause]
given the administration is contemptuous
of Congress this is about time that
Congress held them in contempt find them
maybe even jail them you can't keep
going and allow them to out the laws I
hope you know again a number of us came
to the issue of an inquiry and
impeachment inquiry it was just about a
month ago I think and I was asked the
question many times but before about a
months ago mostly people didn't speak to
me about that they talked about their
economic insecurity and what we were
doing in that regard prescription drugs
and everything else but now it's just
you know it's beyond comprehension
but yeah I'm standing here at Yale Law
School they're probably a lot of lawyers
in this office in this audience you know
helped us you know we're going through a
process as it is you saw what happened
yesterday or what the news is today that
everything that we're doing is in secret
well if you'll go back to the
impeachment of Bill Clinton you know
that there was a special select
committee and Ken Starr did all of the
depositions in private because they
don't want witnesses listening to one
another I'm not a lawyer but that's what
happened we don't have the same kind of
a structure it is the Intelligence
Committee the Foreign Affairs Committee
the Oversight Committee so these
depositions are being held privately
there will be public hearings but you
saw that they stormed the Bastille you
know of or I'm going to ask them if
they're going to do that next honestly
but you know where we go if we are
listening to classified
of information so it's very difficult to
do what you're trying to do with all the
legal minds at this university and
elsewhere you help us because we are a
nation of laws we just don't turn it
around because we feel like it one day
but how do we turn it around and use the
legal profession to get it done because
I do not want to I don't want to
undercut that portion of our democracy
that allows our strengths and and and
committed to the law committed to a an
independent judiciary committed to three
equal branches of government
those are bedrock and we should not fly
in the face of that so I ask your help
on that
after a very divisive 2016 primary
campaign we failed as a party to come
back together to heal and to reunite
sufficiently to win that election what
is the role of the Democratic Party
there was a few who are the leaders of
it to try to prevent that kind of
division that we see all too often right
now in the debates and on the campaign
trail from leading us to defeat again
without putting somebody's thumb on the
scale and unfairly tipping the tipping
the balance and in the election well let
me just for a moment just reflect on
2060 okay now the absolutely upfront I
was a very strong supporter of Hillary
Clinton you know there were a lot of
things that were difficult about the
campaign however and I would not have a
problem having a direct conversation
with Hillary Clinton about this I
believe the campaign was mishandled when
and today about where we would need to
go I think the there wasn't a
realization by Democrats that they
needed to connect again reconnect with
working Americans there was no debate no
discussion about an economic vision
for people who were in deep trouble it
was we're going to continue to create
the jobs you go to the middle of the
country you know you went out to dinner
with people on Saturday night yeah I did
they say how can those people be so
stupid they're not stupid
their lives were falling apart and they
still are they lost a job couldn't get
another one couldn't pay for education
for their kids
couldn't pay for health care watch their
families disintegrate deal with opioid
addiction because that was a way to try
to ass wage what was going on there was
no recognition of the depth of that
economic struggle in 2016 and when you
don't go to Wisconsin Pennsylvania and
Michigan you have missed the boat so it
wasn't a question of being not United in
2016 there are a lot of issues let's
fast-forward to where we are today and
you know surprisingly I hope you believe
me but you know I listened look I'm of
the view I haven't made you know an
endorsement yet I am listening to people
but if you listen to the folks who are
up on this on this stage the scenes are
the saying I just put one out of a hat
health care okay wherever you are on the
spectrum of health care do you
understand that all of the Democrats are
talking about universal health care we
did not have we haven't had that debate
we couldn't have it several years ago
you may want to get it there one way or
the other Medicare for all I have
Medicare for America yeah public option
but my god and they should this should
not be adversarial this is about having
the fulsome the robust debate about how
this country gets to universal health
care
and they're they're they're having that
they're having but the strain that goes
through as well yes look at their focus
on what's going on in middle-class
America the working poor the they're all
talking about that about jobs about how
people get back on their feet about the
rig's system that provides the tax cuts
to the rich is one tenth of one percent
in the country and leaves everyone else
out honestly look yeah do I want them
sniping at one another no I don't I
don't think that that's helpful but in
terms of the content and the poet and
the policy direction there's little
difference and there isn't a division
please do not let the press or others
talk about a division in the Democratic
Party there is more you and I could talk
for the house okay I won't speak to the
Senate
okay which is I call the dark side but
in the house people have difference of
opinion but we are united we understand
look there was a division over whether
or not to move to an impeachment inquiry
I think there may be two or four
Democrats who have not signed on to that
effort and that has mostly to do with
what their districts look like you know
some got elected by the skin of their
teeth in some very very red places we
are not divided we also understand that
you can carry on investigations which is
the point I was making and you can
legislate and we are legislating we're
going to move to prescription drugs
we've done background checks as I said
we did Paycheck Fairness we did the
Equality Act which we couldn't get done
for 15 years so we have to keep from
cannibalizing one another
coming election we have to reconnect
with people in this country who thought
that Democrats don't care about what my
life is about or what's happening to my
family I think we can get there I think
okay thanks again thank you
thank you
thank you very very much thank you thank
you thank you so much appreciated thank
you so what's going on with you I've
been actually thinking but we say what
hey you thank you all right good
so